all that remains from the devastating
tanker explosion in the freetown suburb
of wellington
the blast happened at a busy junction
after a fuel truck collided with another
vehicle
witnesses say crowds of people tried to
collect the leaking fuel before it
suddenly ignited
the resulting fireball incinerated shops
and market halls and engulfed nearby
cars and buses
there are burnt cars and their bodies
underneath we cannot give them one for
access and second decency so waited
until this morning
to us to get a final body count of all
those affected
scores of burn victims are being treated
at freetown's hospitals
the number of patients too overwhelming
to allow families inside
so relatives wait outside for news
scanning a growing list of victims
osmond timbo lost his younger brother
he left home and said he was going to
buy bread for us to eat when i heard
about the explosion i went to the scene
and i saw my younger brother lying down
he was burned all over i felt so bad i
loved him so much
the government has promised the best
care for those affected
we had additional doctors on the ground
and sufficient nurses the government
pharmacy was open
all medicines in the pharmacy was used
to treat the wounded for free
so far they have resources to stabilize
them we have people seriously wounded in
the intensive care unit
sierra leone's underfunded health
service lost hundreds of experienced
workers during the 2016 ebola epidemic
the world health organization says it's
now dispatching supplies and burn
experts to help the west african nation
yet even as the clear up continues
authorities warn the death toll is
expected to rise
alexander lurch al jazeera